l'hommage national ce mercredi à arnaud
beltrame cérémonie aux invalides à paris
mais aussi dans les yvelines
la ville de montigny le bretonneux a
observé aujourd'hui à 14h30 une minute
de silence dans la salle du conseil
municipal
plus d'une cinquantaine de personnes
présentes pour se souvenir du lieutenant
colonel de gendarmerie tomber en héros
il avait pris la place d'une otage dans
le super u de trèbes lors des attaques
terroristes de l'aude vendredi dernier
le gendarme avait succombé ensuite à ses
blessures dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi un sacrifice dont il faut se
rappeler pour le maire de montigny le
bretonneux interrogé par as nicolas
kirillovitch je pense que la démarche
que ce colonel a fait en sacrifiant sa
vie pour sauver celle de quelqu'un
d'autre est tout à fait exceptionnel
dans l'histoire de france et un moment
donné nous en tant qu'élu mais également
tous les représentants de la population
de montigny nous avons souhaité faire
cet hommage
non seulement c'est important mais c'est
même indispensable cette cette barbarie
de l'islamisme c'est en étant tous unis
tous vraiment solidaires qu'on arrivera
jeudi pas à l'éradiquer mais au moins à
la combattre il faut vraiment que nous
soyons fermes sur les valeurs qui sont
celles de la france et que nous nous
battions tous et c'est l'action de nous
tous au quotidien qui permettra je
dirais de passer des messages et de
multiples hommage au lieutenant colonel
de gendarmerie ont eu lieu dans les
yvelines ce graphe d'abord de l'artiste
cette nuit l'oeuvre a été réalisée dans
la nuit de dimanche à lundi dans le
centre ville de port marly ce message
soyons fiers de son courage et
n'oublions jamais son sacrifice
une minute de silence a été aussi suivis
en simultané ce mercredi matin au
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
et à la préfecture à versailles
après des études au lycée militaire de
saint cyr l'école arnaud beltrame avait
été affecté au peloton de véhicules
blindés à satory entre 2002 et 2006 en
2015 il était revenu à versailles pour
intégrer l'école européenne
d'intelligence économique à la ville a
d'ailleurs décidé de donner
une rue le nom est d'arnaud beltrame